this is plural bot her robot is a robot
that we designed to closely mimic a
salamander species called plural del
swelled robot can walk as you can see
here and as you oscillate it can also
swim so you might ask why did we design
this robot and in fact this robot has
been designed as a scientific tool for
neuroscience indeed we designed it
together with no apologies to understand
how animals move and especially how the
spinal cord controls locomotion but more
I working by your buttocks the more I'm
really impressed by animal locomotion if
you think of a dolphin swimming or cut
running or jumping around or even earth
as humans when you go jogging or you
play tennis we do amazing things and in
fact our nervous system solves a very
very complex control problem it has to
correlate moreless 200 muscles perfectly
causing the coordination is bad we fall
over or we do bad locomotion and my goal
is to understand how this works there
are four main components behind animal
locomotion the first component is just
the body and in fact we should never
underestimate what extent the
biomechanics already simplify locomotion
in animals then you have the spinal cord
and in the spinal cord you find reflexes
then multiple reflexes that create
sensory motor coordination loop between
neural activity in the spinal cord and
mechanical activity a third component
our central pattern generators these are
very tracing circuits in the spinal cord
of a debate animals that can generate by
themselves very coordinated rhythmic
patterns of activity while receiving
only very simple input signals and these
input signals come from descending
modulation from higher parts of the
brain like the motor cortex the
cerebellum the basal ganglia will all
modulate activity of the spinal cord
where we do locomotion
but what's interesting is what extent
just a low-level component the spinal
cord together with the body already
solve a big part of the commotion
problem and you probably know it by the
fact that you can cut the head of a
chicken you can still run for a while
showing that just a lower part spinal
cord and body or you solve a big part of
the commotion
now understanding how this works is very
complex because first of all recording
activity in the spinal cord is very
difficult
it's much easy to implant electrodes in
a motor cortex down in the spinal cord
because it's protected by the vertebra
especially in humans very hard to do a
second difficulty is that locomotion is
really due to a very complex and very
dynamic interaction between these four
components so it's very hard to find out
what's the role of each overtime this is
where by robots like Probot and
mathematical models can really help
sowhat's by robotics by robotics is a
very active field of research in
robotics where people want to take
inspiration from animals to make robots
to go outdoors like service robots or
search and rescue robots or field robots
and the big goal here is to take
inspiration from animals to make robots
that can handle complex terrain stairs
mountains forests places where robots
have still difficulties and where
animals can do much better job the robot
can be a wonderful scientific tool as
well there are some very nice project
where robots are used like a scientific
tool for neuroscience for biomechanics
or for hydrodynamics this is exactly the
purpose of Probot so what we do in my
lab is to collaborate with no apologies
like Generic I began a neurologist in
Bordeaux in France and we want to make
spinal cord models and validate them on
robots and here we want to start simple
so it's good to start like with simple
animals like lampreys which are very
primitive fish and then gradually go
towards more complex the commotion like
in salamander but also in cut and in
humans in mammals and here a robot
becomes an interesting tool to validate
our models and in fact for me Probot is
a kind of dream becoming true like more
less twenty years ago I was already
working on a computer making simulations
of lamprey and salamander locomotion
during my PhD but I always knew that my
simulations were just approximations
like simulating the physics in water or
with mud or with complex ground it's
very hard to simulate that properly on a
computer why not have a real robot and
real physics so among all these animals
one of my favorites is a salamander you
might ask why and it's like it's because
of as an Athenian it's a really key
animal from an evolution point of view
it makes a wonderful link between
swimming as you find it in eels or fish
and cut your pet locomotion as you see
in mammals in cat and humans and in fact
the model
amount is very close to the first
terrestrial vector bait so it's almost a
living fossil which gives us us access
to our ancestor the ancestor to all
terrestrial tetrapods so salamanders
swimmed by using what's called an
ungulate from swimming gate so they
propagate a nice traveling wave of
muscle activity from head to tail and if
you place the salmon on ground it
switches to what's called a walking
trough gate in this case you have nice
predict activation of the limbs which
are very nicely coordinated with this
standing wave undulation of the body
that's exactly the gait that you are
seeing here on Probot now one thing
which is very surprising and fascinating
in fact is the fact that all this can be
generated just by the spinal cord and
the body so if you take a dissipated
salamander it's not so nice but you
remove the head and if you electrically
stimulate the spinal cord at low level
of stimulation this will use a walking
like gait if you stimulate a bit more
the gait accelerates and at some point
is the threshold and automatically the
animal switches to swimming this is
amazing just changing the global drive
as if you were pressing the gas pedal of
descending modulation to your spinal
cord makes a complete switch between two
very different gates and in fact the
same has been observed in cat if you
stimulate the spinal cord of a cat you
can switch between walk trot and gallop
or in birds you can make a bird switch
between walking as low level of
stimulation in flapping its wings at
high level stimulation and this really
showed that the spinal cord is is a very
sophisticated locomotion controller so
we studied Salomon the locomotion more
detail and we had in fact access to a
very nice x-ray video machine from
Professor Martin Fisher in Yale
University in Germany and thank to that
you really have an amazing machine to
record all the ball motion in great
detail that's what we did so we
basically figured out which bones are
imported first and collected the emotion
in 3d and what we did is collect a whole
database of motions both on ground and
in water to really collect the whole
database of monkey behaviors that a real
animal can do and then our job as
robotics was to replicate that in our
robot so we did a whole optimization
process to find out the right structure
where to place the motors how to connect
them together to be able to replay these
motions as well as possible and this is
how robot came to life
so let's look how close it is to the
real animal so as you see here is a
almost direct comparison between the
walking of the real animal and the pro
bot and you can see that we have almost
one-to-one exact replay of the walking
gait if you go backwards and slowly you
see even better but even better we can
do swimming so for that we have a dry
suit
that we put all over the robot and then
we can go in water and start replaying
the swimming gait and here here we have
very happy because this is difficult to
do like the physics of interaction are
complex our robot is much bigger than a
small animal so we have to do what's
called dynamical scaling of the
frequencies to make sure we have the
same interaction physics that you see at
the end we have a very close match and
we were very very happy with this so
let's go to the spinal cord so here what
we did with Shan mavica began is model
the spinal cord secret and what's
interesting is that the salamander has
kept a very primitive secret which is
very similar to the one find in the
lamprey this primitive eel-like fish and
it looks like during evolution new
neural oscillated have been added to
control the limbs to do legged
locomotion and we know where these
neural oscillators are but what we did
was make a mathematical model to see how
they should be coupled to allow this
transition between the two very
different gates and we tested that on
board of a robot and this is how it
looks
so what you see here is a previous
version of flora but that's completely
controlled by our spinal cord model
program on both of the robot the only
thing we do is send to the robot through
a remote control the to designing
signals it normally should receive from
upper part of the brain and what's
interesting is by playing with these
signals we can completely control speed
heading and type of gait for instance
when we stimulate at a low level we have
the walking gait and at some part if we
stimulate a lot very rapidly it switches
to the swimming gait and finally we can
also do turning very nicely by just
stimulating more one side of the spinal
cord than the other and I think it's
really beautiful how nature has
distributed control to really give a lot
of responsibility to this power cord so
that the upper part of the brain doesn't
need to worry about every muscle it just
has to worry about this high level
modulation and 3d job of the spinal cord
to coordinate all the muscles so now
let's go to catholic emotion and the
importance of biomechanics so this is
another project where we studied a cat
biomechanics and we wanted to see how
much the morphology helps locomotion and
we found like three important criteria
in the properties basically of the limbs
the first one is that a cat limb more or
less looks like a pantograph like
structure so Pendergraft is the
mechanical structure which keeps the
upper segment and the lower segments
always parallel simple geometrical
system that kind of coordinated it into
a movement of the segments a second
properties of cat limbs is that a very
lightweight most of the muscles are in
the trunk which is a good idea because
then the names have low inertia and can
be moved very rapidly last final
important property is this very elastic
behavior of the cat lame so to handle
impacts and forces and this is how we
design cheetah cub so let's invite
cheetah cub on stage
so this is Peter acre mm HD on on the
this robot and as you see it's a cute
little robot it looks a bit like a toy
bit was really used as a scientific tool
to investigate these properties of the
the legs of the cut so you see it's very
compliant very lightweight and also very
elastic so you can easily press it down
and it will not break I will just jump
in fact and at this very elastic
property is also very important and you
also see a bit these properties of the
three segments of the leg as as
pantograph now what's interesting is
that this quite dynamic gait is obtained
purely in open loop
meaning no sensors no complex feedback
loops and that's interesting because
that it means that just the mechanics
already stabilized is quite rapid gates
and that really good mechanics already
basically simplify locomotion to the
extent that we can even disturb a bit
locomotion as you'll see in the next
video
where we can for insist do some ik
exercise where you have the robot go
down a step and the robot will not fall
over which was a surprise for us that
this is a small perturbation I was
expecting the robot to immediately fall
over because there is no sensors no fast
feedback loop but no just the mechanics
stabilize the gate and the robot doesn't
fall over obviously if you make the step
bigger and if you have obstacles you
need the flow control loops and reflexes
and everything but what's important here
is that's just for small perturbation
the make mechanics are right and I think
this is a very important message from
biomechanics and robotics to
neuroscience saying don't underestimate
what extent the body already helps
locomotion now how does this relate to
human commotion clearly human locomotion
is more complex on cat and salamander
locomotion but at the same time the
nervous system of human is very similar
to that of other vertebrates and
especially the spinal cord is also the
key controller for the commotion in
humans that's why if there's a lesion of
the spinal cord
this has dramatic effect a person can
become paraplegic or tetraplegic
this is because the brain loses this
communication with the spinal cord
especially it loses this descending
modulation to initiate and modulate the
commotion so a big goal of neural
prosthetics is to be able to reactivate
that communication using electrical or
chemical stimulation
and our several teams in the world that
do exactly that especially at EPFL my
colleague Reebok 15 and Silvestre me
Chara with whom I collaborate but to do
this properly it's very important to
understand how the spinal cord works how
it interacts with the body and how the
brain communicates with the spinal cord
and this is where the robots and models
that are presented today will hopefully
play a key role towards these very
important goals thank you
okay I've seen in your lab other robots
that do things like swim in pollution
and measure the pollution while they
swim but for this one you mentioned in
your talk like a side project search and
rescue and it does have a camera on its
nose absolutely so the robot can we have
some spin-off project I would like to
use the robot to do search-and-rescue
inspection so this robot is now seeing
you and the big dream is to if you have
a difficult situation like a collapse
building or a building that half that is
flooded and this is very dangerous for a
rescue team or even rescue dogs why not
send in a robot that can crawl around
swim walk with a camera on board to do
inspection and identify survivors and
possibly create a communication link
with a survivor of course assuming the
survivors don't get scared by the the
shape of this yeah we should probably
change we should probably change the
appearance quite a bit because like here
I guess to survive my die of a heart
attack just of being worried that this
would feed on you but by changing the
appearance and making it more robust I'm
sure we can make it good to us okay
thank you very much thank you and your
team